ils sont quand même très bas la chéchia
home ils sont très malins ils savent
très bien faire leurs produits savent
bien les vendre
il ya quelque temps je vous emmener à
paris avec moi à l'époque je pouvais
vous emmener avec moi pour vous
présenter un des derniers smartphones de
chiots oui c'était notamment le chien
aux milices et pro et semi disent tu es
pro est arrivé celui des pros je voulais
tester ce ministre et proche de vous
faire mon retour je vais vous dire si
l'intérêt sont déjà on va revenir
quelques mois en arrière on va se
remémorer un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé on va regarder ce qui s'est passé
au niveau des flagships de chiens au mit
en ce début d'année ils ont sorti le
1010 et le milices pro et surtout ses
smartphones sont tous mes dix pros se
rapprocher flirter avec les 1000 euros
c'était la première fois penché envie
d'avoir mon smartphone si cher on a donc
ici un smartphone demi génération le mid
east et pro et semi 10 l'épreuve d'hier
est plus dans l'adn de ce qu'on
connaissait de xiaomi des smartphones
haut de gamme très haut de gamme aux
alentours des 500 600 euros et qui
flirte pas ici avec les 1000 euros
alors quelle différence on va voir avec
ceux me disent tu es pro par rapport aux
milices pro est ce qu'il faut aller se
positionner pour acheter ce mid east et
pro ou alors est-ce qu'il faut attendre
que le midi ce propos continuent de
descendre c'est un peu la question qu'on
va se pose aujourd'hui on a regardé
quels sont ses points positifs quels
sont ses points négatifs quelles sont
les limites de ce produit qu'est ce que
vous allez pouvoir faire à m et surtout
est-ce qu'il vous est destiné oui ou pas
du tout mais avant tout vous montrer sur
ce midi ses proches vous invite à venir
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait
pour tout savoir de l'actuelle le test
découvert de smartphones d'ordinateurs
deux mondes connectés
j'en ai de tous les côtés vous invite
donc à cliquer sur le petit bouton rouge
qui est situé juste en dessous actionner
les cloches pour notifier dès qu une
prochaine vidéo sortir qu'est ce qu'on
voit apparaître en premier sur cette
boîte alors effectivement le nom du
smartphone mais surtout ça les 100 8
mégapixels sans 8 mégapixels et on se
dit que ton un smartphone avec son
hummer pixels et marne aujourd'hui ce
qui c'est mieux alors c'est pas
forcément vraiment tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'ici il montre les muscles
c'est vraiment un des arguments de dechy
omis de montrer les muscles avant des
smartphones avec des grosses peck et aux
smartphones qui donne envie qui cette
année est justement je trouve que c'est
plutôt bien réussi on a un smartphone
ici qui donne envie et qui fait baver
première chose sur cet écran comme ça
vous y verrez un petit peu plus clair
vous avez un écran qu'est poinçonnet
petit poisson ici c'est un grand
standard 100 en 2020 donc ça fonctionne
un petit manteau en bas une fois de plus
rien de bien des conneries sur tout
la différence que vous avez ça je vous
l'avais déjà dit quand je vous l'avais
présenter c'est qu'ici vous avez un
écran qui est complètement plat il fera
boulot l'écran est bien très bien
calibrée ya un vrai beau boulot fait de
la part de xiaomi là dessus alors petit
bémol je conseille d'aller si vous
l'achetez dans vos réglages d'affichage
vous allez dans votre schéma de couleur
moi je me suis mis en couleurs
originales
vous pouvez rester comme par défaut en
mode automatique mais je trouve un peu
plus agressif pour les yeux après un
grand standard n'y a rien de bien neuf
là dessus le bouton qui fait office de
capteur d'empreintes digitales de la
recharge en usb c'est le tiroir de
karting qui se trouve là avec double sim
les boutons de volume on voit rien
devient dingue un truc qu'on trouve chez
shiomi qu on trouve pas partout c'est de
l'infrarouge
nous allons pouvoir utiliser votre
smartphone comme une petite télécommande
bon ok rien de banal voilà tu s'asseoir
fois que je trouve un peu lourd quand
même il fait 218 g
on s'y habitue rapidement mais si vous
aimez pas les smartphones qui sont un
peu lourds ce n'était pas celui ci qu'il
vous faudra mois trouve que dans
l'ensemble l'écran est bien bien
maîtrisée écran lcd c'est la différence
qu'on a avec le midi ce procès un écran
oled la cdu lcd on exactement la même
diagonale 6,67 pousse ici on a un truc
qui est vachement bien et qu'on n'a pas
avec le milices pro c'est un taux de
rafraîchissement de 144 m là on est
typiquement dans la stratégie de schumi
qui veut montrer les muscles et qui vous
donnent des specs 144 hertz ça vous
servirait à quoi et c'est destiné à qui
c'est destiné surtout aux technophiles
aux personnes qui veulent ce qui se fait
de mieux aujourd'hui au gamer également
144 hertz est le nombre d'image que vous
avez par seconde c'est à dire qu en une
seconde
vous allez avoir 144 images on va
imaginer que ça c'est une seconde
intervalle de temps on va essayer de
faire un peu de la physique votre
seconde commence là elle se termine là
vous avez dans cet intervalle la 144
images
normalement dans un smartphone classique
on en a 60 mon à plus du double on a eu
les smartphones avec les taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 à l'année
dernière 120 hertz cette année hélas
vous propose c'est du 144 heures ça veut
dire que en une seconde vous allez avoir
plus d'image aucune sensation d'avoir
plus de fluidité lorsque vous allez
venir naviguer sur internet
lorsque vous allez jouer
lorsque vous allez être sur instagram et
c'est vraiment ça le gain qu'on va venir
obtenir avec du 144 isles
alors une fois de plus sa destinée aux
technophiles aux personnes qui veulent
ce qui se fait mieux je suis pas sûr que
pour le commun des mortels ce soit
extrêmement intéressant surtout qu'avec
le met dix pros en début d'année eh bien
vous aviez un tour un fléchissement 90e
donc là la pma vrai gap et il faut le
reconnaître l'expérience est plutôt
convaincante ça marche bien c'est très
fluide c'est hyper agréable ici vous
avez un seul un dragon 865 c'est le même
processeur que vous avez dans le milices
pro autant vous dire que ça fonctionne
vraiment très très très très très bien
coupé à 8 gigas de ram ces deux-là et
pedersen et vous avez ici soit 128 go de
stockage soit 256 ici à techno drame
c'est lui ai fais trois points il faut
savoir qu'avec le milices pro vous à vis
de la 3.0
donc on a aussi ici un vrai gars faut
reconnaître ça marche bien sauf que cet
écran avec son taux de rafraîchissement
plus toute la performance que vous avez
derrière c'est extrêmement optimisé
j'avais beaucoup aimé l'expérience avec
le midi ce projet au ministre qui avait
fait un super boulot et reste dans la
même lignée en termes de performances le
même processeur la même rame une
meilleure technologie de stockage en
lecture et en écriture ça va un poil
plus vite on a un smartphone qui est
complètement optimisé et qui vous permet
d'aller plus loin au niveau de cette
expérience de guémy que ce qu'on avait
avec le milices pro donc pour voir
qu'ici on est un smartphone qui est
quand même beaucoup moins cher le v10
protêt à sa sortie aux alentours de 1000
euros ici on est à un peu moins de 600
euros dans la grosse config avec 256 go
de stockage
là dessus on a rien à redire shiomi a
fait le boulot ok ok ok mais il ya un
truc à savoir c'est qu'ici vous avez un
tout rafraîchissement 144 hertz comme je
voulais dit mais pas uniquement de 144
rc du 144 hertz adaptatif
ça veut dire que vous n'allez pas avoir
en permanence du 144 m si par exemple
d'aller regarder un film ou une série il
se peut que vous soyez en 60 hertz
si vous avez une application qui
nécessitent du 90 ans vous allez montant
90 à 120 à 125 vous comprenez un peu
l'histoire
plus vous allez avoir un nombre d'image
élevée par seconde et plus vous allez
aussi consommé au niveau de votre
batterie
donc c'est tout l'intérêt de ce
smartphone d'ailleurs en parlant de
batterie un truc qui est assez
intéressant
ici vous avez une batterie de 5000
millan terreur contre 4500 militaires
heures avec le milices pro vous avions
une plus grosse base
qui vous permettra d'avoir sensiblement
me sensiblement la même autonomie mais
surtout on a retrouvé sa à l'intérieur
ça c'est le bloc de charge de 33 watts
qui vous permet de le recharger de 0 à
100% en un peu moins d'une heure ça fait
très très bien le taf vouloir charger
vous l'avez vu ici en usb c gepa partie
des plus gros blocs de charges qu'on
puisse connaître aujourd'hui sur du 65
voix de voir plus mais pour un
smartphone mis fin 2020 ça fera très
très bien à faire au niveau de la
recherche qui a omis nous allons savoir
une technologie qui s'appelle mmt qui
permet de le recharger 17% plus
rapidement que ce qu'on pouvait
retrouver avant bon moi j'ai rien
remarqué qu'ils me parlent et c'est
assez dingue tout ce que j'ai remarqué
c'est que je vous le dise recharge de 0
à 100 % en moins d'une heure la recharge
est malgré tout assez rapides ces lieux
bloc de charges 33 watts et je veux bien
croire je suis remis sur parole par
rapport à la technologie elle-même
puisque on se parle d'expérience de
gaming on va également se parler
d'expérience audio qui servira aussi
bien pour lui que pour regarder des
films des séries écouter de la musique
alors il y avait un truc que j'avais
bien aimé moi avec le milices pro c'est
que vous aviez d'eau par la situe
exactement de la même manière ici sur la
partie basse est également sur la partie
haute ça c'était pour le milices pro
avec ce ministère procès différents on
retrouve bien son haut parleur ici et ça
c'est un grand entraîneur mais par
contre on ne l'a pas ici de la même
manière on va utiliser le haut parleur
qui se cachent juste ici ça ça nous
apporte une différence en termes de
spatialisation va pas avoir exactement
la même expérience de spatialisation est
de qualité que ce qu'on avait avec le
1010 pro c'était mieux avec les milices
pro néanmoins avec le midi c'est pro ça
marche quand même vraiment bien
echirolles une fois de plus maîtrise
vraiment sa copie je vous laisse tendre
l'oreille
c'est compliqué de rencontres comme ça
je sais au travers d'un micro enregistré
sur une vidéo youtube je fais la plus
grande partie du scion sortir absolue
par là vous avez si vous allez
effectivement avoir du son qui sort ici
va apporter en termes de spatialisation
pu apporter en terme de qualité mais
c'est pas là dessus qu'on va aller le
plus loin
si vous voulez la meilleure expérience
ces milices pro clairement par contre
l'humidité pro marche plutôt bien vous
délivre un son avec un spectre qui est
assez large
des bandes de fréquences qui vont quand
même jusqu'au grave pour voir qu'on est
un peu moins de 600 euros
on a vraiment une très bonne expérience
audio même si effectivement on va pas
aussi loin que ce qu'on a avec le
smartphone à un peu moins de 1000 euros
de choc bon voilà ici on n'a pas de
prise jack mais sur les smartphones haut
de gamme ça devient de plus en plus
rares par contre ici on a dû me to 5
points pour dire à péret un casque sans
fil 5g un smartphone qui est prêt pour
la 5g grâce au modèle x 55 de cole cote
alors je vous passe le côté un peu
technique et un peu pompeux l'histoire
mais si vous achetez ce smartphone et
que vous envisagez de prendre
l'abonnement 5g en 2021 quand il
arrivera en france ou si vous êtes en
suisse et vous avez déjà la saint jean
et que vous le voulez avec le smartphone
5g parce que vous n'avez pas de
smartphone 5 g est bien celui là sera
très très bien à faire vous avez
également du nfc pour google paye
maintenant ce que je viens lui reprocher
c'est qu'ici vous n'avez absolument
aucune certification eal p 68 il pèse 67
ça veut dire qu'il n'est absolument pas
donner pour être résistant à l'eau et à
la poussière et pour un smartphone un
peu moins de 600 euros
ça ça fait quand même un peu râler autre
point qui fait aussi un peu râler c'est
qu'ici vous n'avez pas de possibilité de
mettre une carte micro sd pour rajouter
l'extension de mémoire bon après déjà
soit 128 soit 256 go de stockage
vous avez largement de quoi faire
l'expérience logiciels et si vraiment
très très bonne avec me wade 12 basé sur
un android 10 alors me wade 12 vous
avait déjà présenté il ya quelques temps
je vais avoir ma vidéo complète pour
tout savoir dessus lorient 9 points qui
est aussi intéressant sur ce smartphone
est qu'il faut vraiment venir moi c'est
justement toute la partie photo eh oui
si on m'y avait vraiment mis le paquet
en début d'année avec ses milices et
milices pro avec le mid east et pro
c'est plutôt bien
c'est moins parfait mais une fois de
plus le prix n'est pas le même schumi
nous propose pas moins de trois caméras
à l'arrière de ce smartphone vous le
voyez si cet écrit vous avez un capteur
principal de 100 8 mégapixels c'est la
même chose que dans le midi trop
l'ouverture est la même
f 1.69 stabilisation optique avec un
zoom numérique x 30 ici pas tel objectif
je l'expliquais dans quelques instants
vous avez juste en dessous ici là juste
là c'est un ultra grand angle de 13
mégapixels touvre f 2.4 avec un champ de
vision de 123 degrés est en dessous ici
ce qui me convainc peu moins mais on va
regarder le reste allant quelques
instants c'est une caméra macro de 5
mégapixels tout bref 2.4 et il faut bien
faire des photos une distance comprise
entre 2 à 10 centimètres tandis qu'à
l'avant vous avez une caméra de saïfi de
20 mégapixels que bref 2.2 et vous
pouvez même venir faire des vidéos en
full hd à 30 images par seconde
il a bien fallu faire des choix ça
aurait pu être le slogan de ce
smartphone
mais au delà des choix xiaomi les fiches
techniques est extrêmement solide je
vous lis sur tous les points
la photo est plutôt bien mais ce que je
regrette toujours et dans cette gamme de
prix
c'est souvent le cas ce sont ces caméras
macro traction me maîtrisait plutôt bien
ça de la crau il ya quelques temps mais
là nous mettre qu'un capteur macro sont
l objectif voyez c'est un peu par en
poste un peu dommage parce que le
téléobjectif apporte vraiment quelque
chose ici effectivement d une caméra de
8 mégapixels qui nous permettra de venir
jouer dans l'image déjà ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que lorsque vous allez
prendre vos photos classiquement avec
votre smartphone vous n'allez pas avoir
une photo de 100 8 mégapixels il va
falloir venir aller dans les paramètres
pour demander à voir les photos de 100 8
mégapixels ici ce que fait schumi c'est
du quatre pixels en or ils vont prendre
4 pixels ils vont vous faire un espèce
de gros pixels pour capter plus de
lumière y avoir une meilleure qualité
d'image ça ça marche très très bien et
ce qui va vous proposer shiomi d'un
point de vue purement logicielle pour
venir zoomer dans l'image et bien c'est
tout simplement vous faire une photo
sans 8 mégapixels et ils vont venir
zoomer ou dézoomer zoomer dans l'image
jusqu'à 1 x 30
alors le point qui est aussi sympa ici
c'est que vous avez un dragon 865 ça je
voulais déjà dit et ce snapdragon 865
vous permet de faire de la vidéo en 8k
jusqu'à 30 images par seconde vous
pouvez également filmé en 4k jusqu en 60
images par seconde je suis pas persuadé
je vous le dis je vous le redis une fois
de plus qu'aujourd'hui il y a un grand
intérêt à venir filmer en 8k ce que fait
xiaomi et ce qu'ils font très bien c'est
ici il ya montré les muscles ce que le
processeur leur permet de venir filmer
jusqu'à 8 k eh bien ils vont mettre en
avant un argument marketing
mais globalement aujourd'hui ça servira
à rien la macro je suis pas très très
fan vous en ai déjà parlé les photos
prises en macro pour moi c'est pas
complètement dingue et c'est toujours un
petit peu dommage difficile à trouver la
bonne distance on dire prendre des
photos il faut absolument pas bouger il
n'y a pas de stabilisation en tout cas
en ce qui me concerne c'est pas génial
et c'est vraiment ce que je reprochais
ici au niveau de la macro
il ya toujours un effet un peu par
moment mais pas tout le temps elles sont
très très durs par contre les photos
prises en extérieur ça marche
merveilleusement bien ce capteur de 100
8 mégapixels est vraiment superbe on est
très très très bon une fois de plus
l'ultra grand temps que ça aussi très
bien des lobes vous avez de la lumière
et je montre le restaurant quelques
instants faible luminosité
et vous vous rapprochez ensuite x 2
c'est très bon x 5 ça marche
x 10 on lisse c'est un peu moins
terrible et on a dû mourir occupée reste
ira notamment au niveau des voitures et
ensuite le x 30 bon ben là c'est
inexploitable
mais par contre les photos avec le
capteur principal sont absolument aucun
zul c'est top je voudrais une fois de
plus c'est vraiment un truc qui marche
très très bien on peut se rapprocher un
peu mais dès qu'on va tout de suite
beaucoup trop près que x 30
on oublie capteur principal luttera
grand-angle x 2 c'est bien
x 5 ça marche mais ça lit ça on ne va
quand même mais c'est pas normal y'a
rien de bien surprenant là dessus le x
10 et le x 30
la caméra de celle ci fonctionne aussi à
subir c'est très honnête franchement le
rendu est très très très bien vous a
refait un peu de macron en extérieur on
arrive dès vous avez beaucoup de lumière
à sentir quelques petites choses mais
une fois de plus c'est pas non plus
magique
les photos nuit je trouve très très bien
avec le capteur principal
je vous ai fait une expo normal palexpo
particulièrement longue vous rendra par
d'autres si vous le souhaitez ça marche
bien
elles sont vraiment bien maîtrisée dès
que vous passez sont ultra grand-angle
c'est absolument pas bon il n'y a pas de
stabilisation la gestion de lumière ne
trouve pas d'un go vous oubliez quatre
principales une fois de plus c'est très
très bien regardez là le ciel on voit
bien les arbres les détails les lumières
tout c'est vraiment vraiment bien
maîtrisée et une fois de plus c'est une
très grand temps qui est pour moi
oublier la nuit en tout cas à la
question est-ce que ce shinobi milices
les pro est une réussite est intéressant
et convaincant et est-ce qu'il est fait
pour moi alors pour la première fille la
question je vous dirais oui c'est
vraiment un très bon smartphone très
très très près bon boulot de la passion
mais une fois de plus il montre les
muscles à un peu moins de 100 euros
dans la plus grosse configuration si
vous intéresse d'ailleurs je vous aimez
les liens en bas dans la description
l'écran est vraiment bien maîtrisé
l'idée d'avoir un taux de
rafraîchissement adaptatif 144 hertz
pourquoi pas ça marche ça me convient en
tout cas l'expérience audio est très
bonne
c'est un smartphone qui est très fluide
grâce au sein dragon 865 toute
l'expérience logiciel est vrai
non mais vraiment agréable grâce à me
wade 12 la partie photo est plutôt bonne
cap top 100 méga pixels fait vraiment
bien le boulot l'ultra grand tombe ce
sera bien lorsque vous avez beaucoup de
lumière c'est un smartphone que je
trouve vraiment complet j'ai omis
continue à mettre la barre très très
haute que je veux vraiment dire était
ici c'est pas téléobjectif pas de
certification ip67 ip68 ça c'est un peu
dommage quand même mais ça reste les
principaux griefs que je pourrais lui
faire sinon le smartphone est vraiment
bien très bien très très très beau
travail de la partition mis d'ailleurs
si vous intéresse une fois de plus je
vous ai mis les liens en bas dans la
description c'est un smartphone qui
coûte en version 256 go 599 euros a vous
de me dire maintenant vous ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire est ce
que c'est un smartphone qui pourrait
vous tentez est ce que vous l'avez déjà
acheté
est ce que vous avez acheté le milices
pro en début d'année 2010 et si vous
avez un smartphone qui a déjà quelques
années que vous envisagez de changer
pour ce smartphone là et bien vous
pouvez y aller tête baissée parce qu'il
est vraiment cool
nous on va beaucoup d'amour a très vite
prenez soin de vous mais le médocain
[Musique]
hélas